mary jane baleazza explains how the
center in the southeast valley helping
child care providers and their families
at the height of covid 19 many child
care businesses closed impacting access
to affordable and quality care for many
families child care provider gail
thompson says the grand opening of
nevada's strong start couldn't have come
in a better time there's licensing help
there's urban league for parents there's
if we have any questions or we need help
doing something
they're here for us nevada's strong
start child care services center is a
one-stop hub providing support and
resources it's something providers say
is much needed during this pandemic
during the pandemic there was a lot of
shutdown so we didn't know like legally
what we needed to do a natural law is
also a child care provider she turned to
nevada strong start to use its resources
to establish an in-home child care
center no one has to spend countless
hours
calling around trying to find where do
you do these things and it just it would
help cut down on the confusion that
takes place because sometimes you can
get information
and it might not be vital thompson says
she knows the struggle families face she
supplies 24 hour child services and is
providing relief for her own family by
watching her granddaughter a lot of my
parents are essential workers anywhere
from front line you know working in
hospitals so i'm just really happy that
we do have better resources now they've
always been there but it's just been
hard to find those resources reporting
from spencer and flamingo mary jane
balleza live local now
nevada strong start is the first of its
kind to open up in las vegas a second
location is slated to open up in reno
this year